am i the a-hole for leaving a family
gathering because my family made me sit
at the kid table for context i haven't
seen my full family together in quite
some time so they set up a get-together
at a park today i get there with some
picnic items i brought a quiche and the
cups so i sit next to my dad and i get a
weird look from my aunt as she says to
me this is the adults table
to which i reply i'm an adult she says
that the first and second generations
are considered adults
and the third and fourth generation
should sit at the kids table i tell her
that i can drink that i drove here and
then i pay rent and have a job so how am
i still considered a child she says that
until i have kids of my own i'll have to
sit at the kids table uh and then he
proceeds to storm out
and he takes his quiche with him and he
leaves and he wants to know if he's uh
yes you are number one because you
brought a quiche okay what kind of man
brings a quiche to a picnic in the first
place i don't even know if i'm
pronouncing that correctly and also
you're childish and ridiculous for
storming out